beweisen sie dass sie auf unserer seite
stehen beweisen sie dass sie uns nicht
im stich lassen beweisen sie dass sie
wirklich europäer sind
das ruft der ukrainische präsident
seelands g der eu zu in einer
eindringlichen videoansprache ins
europäische parlament
für seine rede stehende ovationen ein
paar stunden zuvor verlierer verliess
der russische außenminister lavrov eine
erklärung russlands vor dem
un-menschenrechtsrat die reaktion
dutzende delegierte verlassen aus
protest den raum
und damit herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren zdf spezial
der feind will das herz unseres landes
erobern sagte bürgermeister von kiew
vitali klitschko ein gewaltiger
russischer militär konvoi von über 60
kilometer länge steht vor der hauptstadt
nichts deutet auf entspannung hin am tag
sechs des krieges im gegenteil cornelia
donath mit einem überblick
raketen schlagen im zentrum ein treffen
wohnhäuser und das regionalparlament
kharkiv im nordosten auch heute wieder
ziel heftiger russische angriffe die
worte die präsident so lenski für diese
zerstörung findet russische stadt
terrorismus und der bürgermeister von
kiew nancy völkermord wie viele tote es
gibt keiner weiß es genau mindestens
zehn sollen es hier sein doch die zahl
wird wohl steigen die menschen suchen
schutz in bunkern und dicht gedrängt in
kleinen keller voller angst
wir sind sehr besorgt es ist sehr
beängstigend
hier sind kleine kinder alte menschen
und offen gesprochen wir haben große
angst
aus dem don was kommen diese
symbolbilder die russische flagge weht
gemeinsam mit der der separatisten von
donetsk sie sollen sagen hier gibt es
erfolge zu vermelden unser land kommt zu
uns zurück wir haben lange davon
geträumt und jetzt endlich gelingt es
uns mit der hilfe der russischen
föderation
aber was davon stimmt unklar diese
häuser etwa sollen von ukrainischen
raketen getroffen worden sein die
menschen verzweifelt
im süden sind die hafenstädte seit tagen
unter beschuss am nachmittag verkündet
russland das ukrainische militär habe
keinen zugang mehr zum asowschen meer
der bürgermeister aus mario pohl meldet
sich der strom sei ausgefallen straßen
und häuser zerstört frauen und kinder
tot die stadt bern die anzahl von
russischen streitkräften eingenommen
worden sein bilder auf gestern datiert
zeigen einwohner vor der stadtverwaltung
die sich den russischen soldaten
entgegen stellen sie tragen ihre wut auf
die straße gerufen
zielinski ist unser präsident
auch in kiew wird die lage immer
dramatischer
die hauptstadt ist wohl noch einen
ukrainische hand doch wie lange noch die
sirenen heulen
satellitenbilder zeigen den vormarsch
der russischen truppen mehr als 60
kilometer zieht sich der militärkonvoi
aus panzern und armeefahrzeugen
bürgermeister klitschko mit einem
dramatischen appell
liebe freunde
unsere situation ist kompliziert
der feind ist nahe der vororte der
hauptstadt
unsere armee kämpfte heroisch für unser
land wir bereiten uns vor für zu
verteidigen baut barrikaden an den
eingängen der stadt
auch 30 kilometer vor den toren kiews in
ihre pin errichten ukrainische soldaten
und zivilisten etliche checkpoints und
kontrollen versuche den vormarsch der
russischen truppen aufzuhalten irgendwie
und darüber wollen wir auch heute wieder
mit dem ehemaligen nato general egon
ramms sprechen guten abend
gute neuen
programm ist dieser 60 kilometer langen
konvoi mit russischen truppen fort was
bedeutet das für die hauptstadt
also wie aus den meldungen zu entnehmen
ist ist dies ein konvoi aus gepanzerten
fahrzeugen möglicherweise panzern und
schützenpanzern aber auch lkws besteht
und ich gehe jetzt davon aus dass der
wechsel der russischen truppen vor kiel
verfolgt und mit diesen neuen frischen
truppen den angriff nach kiew
reinzutragen das heißt die russischen
soldaten die bisher das gefecht geführt
haben bleiben da wo sie sind und die
anderen greifen dann über sie hinweg an
aber bisher ist das ein konvoi diese
kräfte sind noch nicht entfaltet auch
diese maßnahmen kosten zeit und wie kann
die stadt im moment überhaupt noch
versagt werden mit lebensmitteln mit
waffen
also würde ich das richtig verfolger aus
dem was mir an informationen zur
verfügung steht gibt es nach wie vor
wege ich sag mal aus dem südwesten von
kiew die nach vier freien führen aber
obwohl die versorgungslage mit
lebensmitteln mit medikamenten deutlich
schlechter geworden ist scheint diese
versorgung zumindest noch zu
funktionieren
muss sein scheint aber auch nicht vor
angriffen in wohnviertel
zurückzuschrecken nimmt also gezielt
zivile opfer in kauf
also in den letzten tagen haben wir
öfter gesehen wie eine rakete in einem
wohnhaus gelandet ist oder auf einem
platz gelandete solo platz runter
gekommen ist und dass diese meldung
haben sich heute in einem relativ
starken maße geholfen so dass sich
mittlerweile davon ausgehe dass die
russische führung auf die
zivilbevölkerung in den heiß umkämpften
bereichen keine rücksicht nimmt was
bedeutet dass der krieg schmutziger wird
und dass wir wahrscheinlich sehr viel
höhere zahlen an zivilen opfern haben
würden na ja auch der fernsehturm in
kiew wurde heute abend beschlossen fünf
tote soll es gegeben haben wie wichtig
sind solche strategischen ziele
also ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass
die russen jetzt versuchen die
kommunikationsinfrastruktur anzugreifen
dazu gehören fernsehtürme dazu gehören
verteilerstationen dazu gehören alle
arten von netzen versorgungsnetzen und
das hat den eindeutigen zweck
die zivilbevölkerung von der information
die sie durch die regierung oder
vielleicht doch durch das militär noch
bekommt abzuschneiden und auf diese art
und weise die angst bei der
zivilbevölkerung aufgrund fehlender
informationen deutlich zu erhöhen das
ist ein krieg in dieser form der
schlicht und einfach darauf abzielt
zivilbevölkerung streitkräfte und
regierung voneinander zu trennen und ich
gehe davon aus dass die russen so wie
sie auch heute aufgetreten sind dieses
in den nächsten tagen in massiver form
fortsetzen werden jetzt wollen wir
natürlich auch noch wissen wie es den
menschen in der ukraine geht vielen dank
general ramms
gerne danke
und in kiew bin ich jetzt verbunden mit
der ukrainischen journalistin anna
kuschtschenko können sie uns kurz
schildern wie ihre situation ist
ja gut und
was bekommen sie von den angriffen mit
ist ihre wohnung sicher
eigentlich in der probe
verstecken sie sich
aber es ist eben zu mitte dort zu sein
also jetzt verstecke ich mich in meine
wohnung in oslo war weil dort die wende
am dicksten sich also ich habe bemerkt
möglichkeiten
welche informationen haben sie dann von
freunden und verwandten bis die
situation dort
diese
unserem
[Musik]
haus getroffen im moment war nicht im
versteck vielleicht wollte er etwas
widmen also
mein beileid dazu sie wollen in kiew
bleiben
natürlich diese morgen danach habe ich
noch einen angebot von einer von meinen
freunden ausleihen wollen bekommen dass
ich nach hamburg umziehen soll aber aber
mich hier entscheidet es gibt bleibe in
trier wir
mit unserer fläche werde hierbleiben um
unsere strafe zu schützen und zu kämpfen
vielen dank einer kostenkur wir wünschen
ihnen natürlich alle viel kraft und dass
sie gesund bleiben will und dann
das gespräch haben wir aus
sicherheitsgründen vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet
westlich von kiew ist für uns jetzt live
katrin eigendorf wie ist denn die
situation bei ihnen
also ich weiß nicht mal dass im
hintergrund hört wir haben jetzt gerade
hier auch wieder feueralarm in unserem
hotel gehen die leute jetzt hier in den
bunker und wir können uns auch nicht zu
lange mehr hier draußen aufhalten es
gibt hier immer wieder alarm auch hier
ist die stimmung äußerst angespannt es
ist einfach so an dass an diesem
sechsten kriegstag die menschen in der
ukraine und auch hier sehen dass putin
immer mehr zivilisten ins visier nimmt
das was wir heute in kharkiv gesehen
gezielte bombardierungen der innenstadt
das was im prinzip jetzt kiew erwartet
das beunruhigt die menschen doch sehr
und sie teilen natürlich über die
sozialen medien auch informationen aus
es werden immer mehr videos geteilt auch
über die situation in verschiedenen
orten es ist so dass wohl in den jetzt
im osten der ukraine mittlerweile ganze
stadtteile abgetrennt sind und kann
nicht mehr versorgt werden mit wasser
und essen und dort im prinzip auch
nichts mehr hin gebracht werden kann
also die menschen richten sich an vielen
orten der ukraine darauf ein dass sie
mit heftigen
beschlüssen rechnen müssen dass ihre
versorgung im prinzip ab gekappt wird
unter sie sich hier auf einen langen
krieg eigentlich vorbereiten müssen und
ich habe das gefühl dass die stimmung an
diesem sechsten tag des krieges sagen
wir mal ein bisschen gekippt ist von dem
ursprünglich doch sehr positiven gefühl
der russischen armee etwas
entgegensetzen zu können
zu mehr verzweiflung doch ja dass hier
auch die zivilisten sehr viele opfer
eigentlich hinnehmen müssen und ich
liebe sehr viele leute die einfach jetzt
wein verzweifelt sind
vielen dank für diesen bericht aus der
ukraine
katrin eigendorf
ja die welt blickt entsetzt auf den
krieg in europa wie weit wird putin
gehen in der ukraine scheint er
inzwischen von nichts zurückzuschrecken
und dann sind da ja auch noch die
atomwaffen die ankündigung putins die
abschreckungs waffen in erhöhte
alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen erinnert
an die schlimmsten zeiten des kalten
krieges doch wie sieht die situation
überhaupt aus welcher atomwaffen gibt es
und wer kann sie wie auslösen lukas ayla
und rené severin über die atomare
bedrohung
gefahr durch atomwaffen das
worst-case-szenario
schätzungen des
friedensforschungsinstituts sipri zeigen
circa 13.000 nuklearwaffen gibt es
weltweit mit abstand am meisten
atomwaffen gibt es in russland gefolgt
von den usa auf platz drei china
auf frankreich und das vereinigte
königreich besitzen atomwaffen außerdem
pakistan indien israel und nordkorea
doch atomwaffe ist nicht gleich
atomwaffe unterschieden wird zwischen
strategischen und taktischen
nuklearwaffen
strategische atomwaffen können mehr als
5500 kilometer distanz zurücklegen etwa
von moskau nach washington und ganze
regionen zerstören
kleinere taktische atomwaffen können
dagegen weniger weit fliegen und haben
eine geringere sprengkraft sie können
objekte gezielter angreifen wie diese
waffen aktiviert werden hängt von der
jeweiligen atommacht ab in russland gibt
es zb drei atom koffer ausgestattet mit
einem kommunikationssystem und codes den
ersten koffer besitzt präsident putin
den 2 der russische
verteidigungsminister sergej schoigu der
als guter freund putins gilt der dritte
ist beim chef des generalstabs der
russischen streitkräfte valérie gasimov
um atomwaffen zu aktivieren wurden bis
anfang der 90er alle drei koffer
benötigt aktuell geht man davon aus dass
nur noch zwei gebraucht werden zuletzt
waren die koffer nicht aktiv russland
befand sich in stufe eins seines atom
stufenplans doch am sonntag hat wladimir
putin befohlen die atomstreitkräfte in
erhöhte alarmbereitschaft zu versetzen
damit tritt stufe zwei in kraft truppen
sind in dauerhafter bereitschaft in
stufe drei militärischer gefahr werden
die werfen scharf gemacht stufe 4
bedeutet tatsächlichen krieg mit
nuklearwaffen
in den usa gibt es ebenfalls drei atom
koffern die befehlsgewalt liegt bei
präsident joe biden als er stirbt ist
ein zweiter bei vize-präsidentin kamera
harris und einer beim sogenannten
designierten überlebenden falls beide
sterben mit codes identifiziert sich der
präsident um die waffen auszulösen
us atomwaffen sind auch in deutschland
gelagert auf dem luftwaffenstützpunkt
büchel in der eifel sollen etwa 15 bis
20 us-atombomben liegen
dahinter steckt das nato konzept der
nuklearen teilhabe
dabei werden an der übung und planung
von us atomwaffen einsetzen auch
mitgliedsstaaten ohne eigene
nuklearwaffen einbezogen die absolute
kontrolle liegt allerdings weiter bei
den usa zuletzt versicherte joe biden
die amerikaner müssten sich keine sorgen
um einen atomkrieg machen eine längst
vergessene angst die jetzt durch den
russischen präsidenten wieder geschürt
wird
und in bonn begrüße ich jetzt joachim
weber sicherheitsexperte beim think tank
der uni bonn guten abend
gute nacht op werden müssen wir uns
wirklich fürchten dass wladimir putin
bis zum äußersten geht und die atombombe
gezündet
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt müssen wir das
sicherlich nicht befürchten was bisher
geschehen ist ist dass die russen einen
level in der bereitschaft ihrer
strategischen lukas rath kräfte
herausgegangen sind dass es ja bei den
russen ein vier stufen system bei den
amerikanern in fünf stufen system aber
dieses herausgehen einen level
beschreibt sozusagen nur das
tatsächliche ausmaß der krise und das
ausmaß der gefahr aber das ist noch weit
entfernt davon wirklich bedrohlich zu
werden es ist eine drohgebärde
was ist denn für sie das gefährlichste
an der lage im moment
naja das gefährlichste an der lage
glaube ich liegt darin dass für drohen
auf eine abschüssige bahn zu geraten und
wir verstehen alle weil wir ja auch alle
mit der ukraine führen sie es opfer
eines eines brutalen angriffs krieges
wir verstehen alle und wollen alle die
ukraine unterstützen und das ist auch
richtig und gut dass wir das tun wir tun
das politisch wir tun das wirtschaftlich
wir tun das auch zunehmend militärisch
letzteres muss uns auch beginnen ein
bisschen sorgen zu machen es ist richtig
dass wir die ukraine an defensivwaffen
zu ihrer verteidigung liefern die
panzerfäuste die stinger
flugabwehrraketen die durchaus ein
kleines stück heizung game changer
werden könnten aber wir müssen auch
sehen dass wir nicht in eine situation
hinein geraten in der der westen eu nato
anfängen die die logistik sozusagen der
kriegführenden ukrainischen armee zu
übernehmen dann drohen wir kriegspartei
zu werden und dann sind die eskalation
risiken höher sie werden dann bedeutend
höher als sie möglicherweise bisher
gewesen sind heute sprach ja moskauer
davon dass die ukraine angeblich selbst
versuche atomwaffen zu bekommen wie
glaubhaft ist das denn
das halte ich für wenig glaubhaft auch
in keiner weise für nachvollziehbar da
scheint mir eher ein element der
psychologischen kriegsführung zu sein
was deutlich machen sollen nach außen
die ukraine ist schlimm die ukraine
bedroht russland ist stellt die
verhältnisse auf den kopf die ukraine
bedroht wirklich das mächtige russland
nicht wir sehen jeden tag wie russische
streitkräfte in der ukraine agieren
schießen und bomben es gibt aber keine
ukrainischen streitkräfte die in
russland schießen oder bomben es würde
auch überhaupt keinen sinn machen aus
ukrainischer perspektive denn selbst
wenn sie ein oder zwei atombomben sich
verschaffen sollte die kann sie doch
überhaupt nicht einsetzen in dem moment
in dem sie in irgendeiner weise damit
gegen gegen russland losging und die
gegen die russin einsetzen würde dann
würde sie so einen vernichtenden
atomaren gegenschlag der russen erleben
also so verrückt kann und wird niemand
an
das gespräch haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet live in new york ist für
uns johannes hano sie beobachten eine
dringlichkeitssitzung der
un-vollversammlung wie wird dort die
atomare bedrohung gesehen die gesamte
welt ordnung scheint ihr auf den kopf
gestellt
ja es ist nicht das erste mal dass
russland mit der einsatzbereitschaft
seiner streitmacht droht die neue
qualität ist dass wladimir putin jetzt
ja auch mehr oder weniger unverhohlen
damit gedroht sie einzusetzen sollten
fremde mächte in diesem konflikt
eingreifen und das hat eine tatsächlich
völlig neue qualität das hat viele hier
geschockt die un generalsekretär hat
gestern klipp und klar gesagt was die
russland weißrussland gerade in der
ukraine macht ist ein bruch mit der
charta der vereinten nationen und
deshalb völlig inakzeptabel mit dem
einsatz von nuklearwaffen auch nur
unverhohlen zu drohen das hat sich heute
auch durch die ganzen reden gezogen
china das ist interessant hat sich dazu
nicht geäußert man hat zwar hat
aufgerufen nicht weiter zu eskalieren
aber man hat auch die nukleare bedrohung
nicht wirklich in den mund genommen
jetzt wird eine resolution hier
vorgestellt die morgen verabschiedet
werden soll darin wird russland
aufgefordert die truppen abzuziehen der
krieg wird verurteilt und das ist jetzt
auch dazu gekommen es wird verurteilt
dass russland seine nuklearmacht
hochfährt also die einsatzfähigkeit
hochfährt jetzt müssen wir morgen sehen
wieviel länder sich hinter diese
resolution stellen diplomaten sagen hier
alles was über 100 länder ist sei ein
erfolg 100 von 193 ich persönlich weiß
nicht ob man das ein erfolg werden kann
vielen dank johannes hano und über die
atomaren risiken gibt es heute ab 20 uhr
15 auch ein zdf heute live mit ihren
fragen an experten
wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen das wird
noch eine ganz ganz dramatische zeit die
bilder von toten und verletzten sowie
zerstörte gebäude sei nur ein anfang von
dem was wahrscheinlich noch kommt warnte
heute bundeskanzler olaf scholz ist der
anfang schon jetzt ist die lage
dramatisch gert anhalt über krieg flucht
und verzweifelte gegenwehr
ist das die schlinge mit der kiew
erdrosselt werden soll satelliten
entdeckten den militär konvoi über 60
kilometer lang der sich von norden her
auf die hauptstadt zu bewegt wo immer
noch die sirenen die seit dem wochenende
geltende ausgangssperre begleiten auch
in der vergangenen nacht gab es in den
randbezirken wieder raketenangriffe wie
private aufnahmen aus dem internet
zeigen mischa wir müssen schneller
fahren drängt der beifahrer der die
bilder macht das da ist der armee
stützpunkt wer weiß ob da jemand
überlebt hat
drei ukrainische soldaten haben diesen
angriff jedenfalls nicht überlebt
mindestens acht wurden verletzt
auch die angreifer geben inzwischen
videos heraus wo und wann ihr
kampfhubschrauber zuschlug teilte das
russische verteidigungsministerium
nicht mit anscheinend will es mit
solchen szenen der zerstörung meldungen
konnten nach denen der vormarsch den sie
immer noch
spezialoperation nennen ins stocken
geraten sei von ukrainischer seite
wurden 70 todesopfer bestätigt die bei
einem russischen angriff auf eine
stellung in der stadt circa 100
kilometer nordwestlich von hartz iv
getötet worden sind
die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine nur 30
kilometer von der russischen grenze
gelegen war gestern schon ziel eines
bombenhagel heute dann schlug eine
rakete im gebäude der stadtverwaltung
ein
trümmer rauch und scherben am
freiheitsplatz im zentrum der 1,4
millionen statt es ist einer der größten
innerstädtischen plätze europas wo bis
2014 sogar noch eine lenin statue stand
denn hier im russisch geprägten teil der
ukraine nahm man nur schwer abschied vom
sowjetreich aber mit putins
angriffskrieg und dem leid das er über
die ukraine bringt dürfte der bruch nun
endgültig sein
bürger von car kit erklärt der
bürgermeister in einer videobotschaft
aus dem luftschutzbunker was uns trifft
das ist nicht nur krieg das ist mord an
uns den ukrainischen volk so etwas
erleben wir zum ersten mal in unserer
langen geschichte bomben haben
wohnhäuser zerstört und unschuldige
zivilisten getötet oder verstümmelt
erinnerst du dich an das konzert das du
2008 genau hier gespielt hast fragt ein
user aus charkiw den queen gitarrist
brian may nun so sieht der platz heute
aus bitte hilf uns und beantwortet mit
diesem foto wir alle sind entsetzt und
schockiert über die invasion wir beten
für euch
beten und hoffen mehr können auch sie
nicht tun die hochschwangeren und die
jungen mütter auf der entbindungsstation
des krankenhauses von kalkhoff die
hinter die schützen den betonmauern
eines hoffentlich sicheren kellers
umgezogen ist weil niemand mehr sicher
ist vor den immer rücksichtsloser
agierenden russischen truppen
die angriffe auf das friedliche hartz
urteil präsident selensky haben nicht
nur militäreinrichtungen sondern der
vernichtung von menschenleben gegolten
es wird für diese verbrechen einen
internationalen kriegsverbrecher prozess
geben diese verletzung aller
vereinbarung und die ermordung
friedlicher ukraine wird die welt
niemals vergeben sagt er
immer wieder gelingt es der hoffnungslos
unterlegenen ukrainischen armee den
vormarsch der russen zumindest zu
verlangsamen und ihnen verluste
beizubringen hier werden unter dem jubel
der zeugen russische hubschrauber beim
überqueren des klipper abgeschossen
und in den sozialen netzwerken finden
sich zahlreiche zeugnisse vom beherzten
und verzweifelten eingreifen der
ukrainischen zivilgesellschaft gegen die
angreifer hier angeblich in der stadt
koblenz
beeindruckend aber unmöglich zu
verifizieren
doch wenn man wie auf diesen handy
bildern sieht welche massive übermacht
die invasionsarmee mittlerweile auf die
piste bringt diese hier mutmaßlich heute
früh auf den weg nach kef dann braucht
es wohl mehr als nur mut um diesen
angriff zu überstehen
die hast dich an allen wichtigen routen
im land eingerichteten checkpoints
bemannt von reservisten und freiwillige
sind nicht mehr als bodenschwellen für
die russen
meine frau und meine sechs kinder sind
zu hause in charkiw vorgestern habe ich
beschlossen dass ich mich bewaffnen und
meine stadt beschützen muss
andere haben sich sofort nach dem
angriff der russen am vergangenen
donnerstag dem heimatschutz
angeschlossen
ich habe mein jagdgewehr mitgebracht
damit treffe ich auf 100 meter genau
und während sie hier die opfer des
morgendlichen beschusses bergen und sich
auf eine weitere schlimme nacht und
womöglich das einfallen der bodentruppen
einrichten ist 1000 kilometer westlich
die jugend von lemberg dass die ukraine
will nennen mit der herstellung von
tarnnetzen befasst
bisher ist die stadt zwar nur von
einigen luft alarmen alarmiert worden
doch ist die bevölkerung auch hier auf
das schlimmste gefasst und beteiligt
sich an den verteidigungsanstrengungen
viele leute wollen für unsere truppen
kochen oder eben netze knüpfen oder
blutspenden sie wollen alles tun um
unsere soldaten zu unterstützen
aber lemberg ist auch die stadt des
abschieds des verzweifelten gedränges
und die stadt der tränen denn von hier
fahren die übervollen zügen und bringen
die flüchtenden hinüber ins nahe polen
und niemand weiß ob es ein abschied nur
für kurze zeit ist oder vielleicht für
immer
genau dorthin nach lemberg gehen wir
jetzt zu unserem reporter armin coerper
die stadt liegt rund 550 kilometer
westlich von kiew jeden tag kommen dort
tausende flüchtlinge aus dem rest des
landes an
armin wie geht es der menschen vor ort
also die menschen die hier ankommen sind
natürlich erschöpft ist und menschen aus
zentral aus der zentrale ukraine und dem
osten des landes die kommen hier mit
autos mit zügen mit allem möglichen hier
an und die stadt versucht damit
irgendwie umzugehen und dem herr zu
werden sie hat sieben zentrale
flüchtlingsaufnahme stellen eingerichtet
über 150 nicht kirchliche organisationen
kümmern sich um diese leute und 100
kirchliche organisationen das heißt man
versucht hier zu helfen wie es irgendwie
geht aber die stadt kommt dann natürlich
an ihre grenzen ja wir hören dass der
flughafen in lemberg noch intakt ist wie
wichtig ist dass in dieser situation
genau der flughafen scheint einer der
letzten des landes zu sein die noch
intakt sind das heißt man versucht mit
allen mitteln den jetzt zu verteidigen
wie ich heute höre sind auch die der
großteil der raketenabwehrsysteme über
die die ukrainischen streitkräfte
verfügen aktuell hier in lemberg und das
gilt vor allem dem flughafen wir erleben
das aber auch in der stadt dass es immer
wieder alarm gibt sirenen
lautsprecherdurchsagen dass man sich in
sicherheit bringen muss weil man eben
angst hat vor luftangriffen
ich vermute er auf dem flughafen als
aktuell auf der stadtzentrum aber die
stimmung ist natürlich angespannt vielen
dank an mein körper
mit sanktionen wilder westen putin
stoppen zumindest eine weitere
eskalation verhindern inzwischen hat
sich auch die schweiz die bisher so sehr
auf neutralität setzte den maßnahmen der
eu angeschlossen dazu gehört das
einfrieren von vermögenswerten reiche
russen verlieren damit den zugang zu
einer ihrer bevorzugten finanzoasen den
sie bisher ihr geld parken konnten die
vorschüler uns wenn glas
solidarität mit den menschen in der
ukraine tausende gehen gestern in zürich
auf die straße wenige stunden zuvor
hatte die schweizer regierung nach
langem zögern auf internationalen druck
beschlossen die eu sanktionen gegen
russland zu übernehmen eine zäsur in der
geschichte der schweiz für die
neutralität bislang oberstes gebot war
warum haben wir so entschieden
andere demokratien sollen sich auf die
schweiz verlassen können
starten die für völkerrecht einstehen
sollen sich auf die schweiz verlassen
können die schweiz beliebter rückzugsort
russischer oligarchen putins
jugendfreund milliardär und ölhändler
dem kongo lebt in einer luxuriösen villa
am genfer see oligarch vekselberg lenkt
von zukauf sein firmennetzwerk beide
stehen schon länger auf der us
sanktionsliste das hat sich gar nicht so
viel ändern werde relativiert die
bankiersvereinigung die international
orientierten banken in der schweiz haben
sich seit de schon immer haben die ist
alles anders sanktionen der usa oder der
eu gehalten mit dem entscheid übernimmt
die schweizer nun dieser sanktionspaket
der eu vollständig und damit herrscht
klarheit gibt keine lücken keine
ausnahme mehr 15 milliarden an
russischen vermögenswerten liegen laut
schweizer nationalbank auf schweizer
konten das entspricht rund einem drittel
des geldes das wohlhabende russen im
ausland angelegt haben es ist davon
auszugehen dass nur ein geringer teil
von dem konkreten sparmaßnahmen jetzt
der eu und auch der schweiz erfasst
werden die anderen sollten normale
russische geschäftsleute sein
die von den sanktionen nicht jeden raus
oder noch nicht betroffen sind denn
eingefroren werden nur vermögen von
personen die auf der eu sanktionsliste
stehen die frage ist also wie
weitreichend die sanktionen wirklich
sind die in zürich lebende ehemalige
russische diplomaten und politologin
natalia basler koffer möchte putin nicht
offen kritisieren findet die neue linie
der schweiz aber richtig
ist sehr wichtig aber die eingeführte
sanktionen finde ich auch sag mal so gut
weil schweiz in diesem sinne geht in der
richtung
europa und
stoppt die möglichkeit die leuten
benutzen schweiz um die sanktionen
umzugehen die schweiz vollzieht einen
historischen strategiewechsel gibt ein
stückchen neutralität auf die
auswirkungen auf den finanzplatz werden
sich aber wohl in grenzen halten und
in moskau selbst wirken sich dort die
sanktionen aus bevor ich mit dem
russland experten karl schlögel über
putins pläne sprecher achim flora über
ein land zwischen propaganda und
zunehmender sorge
vielleicht ist es das harmloseste was
ein mensch tun kann aber die menschen
die hier blumen niederlegen gehen dabei
ein großes risiko ein russen vor der
ukrainischen botschaft in moskau sie
wollen zeichen setzen
ich bin hier um unterstützung zu zeigen
für die menschen in der ukraine
ich weiß aber nicht ob das unsere
führung beeinflussen wird um diesen
bruder krieg zu beenden
ich bin gekommen um meine anteilnahme zu
zeigen für die menschen die in dieser
militärischen auseinandersetzungen in
der ukraine gefangen sind
putins creek ist weit weg von moskau und
doch ist er auch hier angekommen bei
menschen und banken die sanktionen des
westens greifen psychologisch vor allem
der rubel gestern abgestürzt um 30%
viele fürchten um ihre ersparnisse oder
das westliche konsumgüter schon bald
nicht mehr erhältlich sind riesige
schlangen vor den geldautomaten
ich habe angst dass die regierung alles
geld einzieht oder dass die bankkarten
eingefroren werden ich habe es schon an
verschiedenen automaten versucht immer
schlange gestanden den zweiten tag jetzt
die sorgen der einfachen russen für die
hinter den hohen mauern des kreml
spielen sie wohl gerade keine rolle der
präsident ein kriegsherr geächtet
sanktioniert aber derzeit auch irgendwie
unsichtbar und schweigend putin schickt
sprecher vor um diesen krieg der
angeblich gar keiner ist den landsleuten
zu erklären heute dank der
verteidigungsminister den russischen
truppen für ihre heldenhaft ich kite die
spezial operation werde fortgesetzt alle
gesetzten ziele werde man erreichen
ihr ziel ist frieden demonstranten in
sankt petersburg die staatsmacht greift
durch wieder verhaftungen mittlerweile
sind es über 7000 dennoch die kriegs
unlust unter den russen wächst
menschen sterben menschen leiden es gibt
zerstörung niemand kann ihnen ihr leben
zurückgeben herzen werden gebrochen der
hass aufeinander wird doch nur von
generation zu generation weitergegeben
die demonstranten eine minderheit in
putins reich noch funktionieren
propaganda und einschüchterung von
kriegs verlauf wird abhängen wie lange
noch tja und in berlin spreche ich jetzt
mit dem historiker und russland expertin
kaltstellen guten abend
herr
schlegel wie schätzen sie die situation
in russland zurzeit ein kann überhaupt
noch jemand vladimir putin stoppen
die stimmung ist klar wie bedrückt es
gibt ein ganzes register von äußerungen
es ist so dass erstaunlicherweise nicht
nur in den hauptstädten in petersburg
und in moskau leute auf die straße
gegangen sind sondern draußen im weiten
land in so genannten provinzstädten und
es ist ganz erstaunlich die breite der
wortmeldungen wir haben
ärzte mitglieder der akademie der
wissenschaften die komiker journalisten
im grunde haben sich alle berufsgruppen
gemeldet und so eine breite
von wortmeldungen protesten hat es gar
nicht gegeben
das aber in einem land in denen die
öffentlichen medien vollständig unter
kontrolle
des staates sind und jeden abend
eine ungeheure
kriegshetzerischen propaganda läuft und
natürlich eine komplette zensur es gibt
ja keine nachrichten über den krieg der
er auch gar nicht krieg genannt werden
darf aber es gibt eben stimmen ich
möchte nur erinnern an murat of dem
herausgeber der novell kassierte der
eine rede gehalten hat wir schämen uns
geschehen uns und ich glaube das ist
eine verbreitete stimmung auch eine
fassungslosigkeit dass es dazu gekommen
ist dass russland die ukraine angreift
es gibt aber auch versuche von staats zu
mobilisieren eine art von enthusiasmus
zu erzeugen für den 12 märz sind
demonstrationen zur unterstützung der
armee angekündigt das sind aber glaube
ich hilflose versuche um der wahrheit
die auch in russland irgendwie trotz
zensur
durchsickern wird um den etwas
entgegenzustellen
also es herrscht
oberflächlich gesehen eine ruhe es gibt
einzelne die auf die straßen gehen wolle
ich glaube dass insgesamt die zeit gegen
putin arbeitet weil die bilder zumal in
unserer zeit mit den neuen medien sie
sich an alle nach russland ein und hier
kommt etwas zum tragen was
offensichtlich nicht verstanden wird von
der führung die beziehungen die
familiären beziehungen zwischen russen
und ukrainern sind so eng
verwoben
millionenfach und es ist völlig
ausgeschlossen dass diese furchtbaren
bilder von der bombardierung des
zentrums von st
und ich war eigentlich halte ich auf
diesem platz ich habe dieses gebäude
gesehen dieses gebäude ist zweimal
zerstört worden einmal von der wehrmacht
ein konstruktivistischer baute 20er
jahre und jetzt von den tropen putins
niemand wer weiß was der krieg der
deutschen in der sowjetunion war wird
vergessen können bilder die jetzt aus
der ukraine nach russland kommen dort
einsickern werden ganz egal was die
zensur und was ein putin
versucht zu kontrollieren die verbindung
sind sehr eng wie sehr schaden ihn denn
eigentlich die sanktionen welche rolle
spielen die oligarchen
es gibt ja jetzt schon bestimmte
wortmeldung dass einzelne oligarchen auf
distanz gehen oder sogar kritische worte
gefunden haben den kopf es gibt so
kritischen bemerkungen habe ich gelesen
von deripaska und einigen anderen
ich bin aber der auffassung dass diese
distanzierung oder es gibt keine anti
kriegspartei
bisher sondern es gibt ein
man traut sich offensichtlich niemand
aus diesem kreis und ich habe den
eindruck dass putin
seinem volk alles zumuten und alles
zumuten wird und dass er glaubt immer
noch dass er ein durchmarsch machen wird
in der ukraine
und das in einer art festung ökonomie
den folgen der sanktionen die gewiss
gravierend sind widerstehen kann aber
die folgen dieser sanktionen die werden
auf mittlere und längere sicht wirken
sie haben jetzt unmittelbar auf das
kräftemessen auf die verteidigung der
ukraine durch die ukraine keinen
einfluss die einzigen die putin stoppen
können im augenblick das sind die vielen
dank karl schlögel es sicherlich noch
vieles zu besprechen gerne in den
nächsten tagen danke
die größte flüchtlingskrise in europa in
diesem jahrhundert sei zu befürchten
erklärte das un flüchtlingshilfswerk
heute mehr als
660.000 menschen seien bisher aus der
ukraine geflohen hilfsbereitschaft und
solidarität sind groß auch in
deutschland dann jeder hilft
die bereitschaft zu helfen irgendwie zu
unterstützen ist enorm seit tagen schon
in potsdam zum beispiel bringen
einwohner spenden für die ukraine wasser
warme kleidung hygieneartikel
organisator paul malinowski ist
überwältigt
abgegeben ich habe im wechsel sagt neues
willst du das wirklich abgeben und er
meinte ja viele kindern ukraine
strohmann sind die spenden sollen in die
west ukraine gehen paul malinowski hat
dort selbst verwandte diese hilfe zu
organisieren ist ihm auch persönlich
wichtig dass eine richtige sache man
muss das mal gemacht dass mit dem herz
mit dem kopf wenn man das gar nichts tut
und sitzt da und wartet ab das bringt
nicht auch im ganz privaten funktioniert
die hilfe an amano china ist mit ihren
kindern aus der ukraine geflohen vier
tage waren sie unterwegs
1700 kilometer haben sie zurückgelegt
als in ihrer heimat dem norden des
landes die ersten bomben fielen
wir haben matratzen decken und kissen
von zu hause mitgenommen und auf die
ladefläche des transporters gelegt dann
sind wir zur polnischen grenze gefahren
meine größte angst war dass der bus
abgeschossen wird dass wir von einer
rakete getroffen werden ich hatte
einfach angst dass wir da nicht lebend
rauskommen
doch es gelingt mit hilfe von freunden
auch aus deutschland die kleine familie
findet zuflucht bei margarita liebelt
china und ihrem partner zimmer fei
bureau kopf im münsterland
margarita stammt aus russland zimmer aus
belarus dass die beiden anja und die
kinder aufnehmen ist für sie eine
selbstverständlichkeit schließlich ist
dies nicht ihr krieg
ich bin selber auch russen das ist ganz
schrecklich was jetzt passiert und was
meine land und war sehr fest
veranstaltet und damit zusätzlich auch
ein zeichen dass die russen nie so
schlimme sind nicht alle russen denken
so denn ganz gleich ob aus der ukraine
russland oder belarus diesen krieg hat
hier niemand gewollt
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine
helfen wollen können sie das tun beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden zdf de oder im zdf
text auf seite 8 190
das war es von uns am tag sechs des
krieges in der ukraine eine katastrophe
hat wladimir putin mit seinem angriff
ausgelöst und die wird von tag zu tag
größer beim die großstädte sind nun
unter beschuss kiew im visier hier live
bilder aus der hauptstadt wo es jetzt in
diesem moment noch ruhig zu sein scheint
wir informieren sie weiter jederzeit in
der zdf- heute- app und natürlich später
im heute journal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
der eine moment der alles verändert
der überfall ab weiter 21 15
[Musik]